it's chaos on the streets people are
running as fast as they can as monsters
and Horrors Beyond imagination spill out
of every Alleyway a monstrous reptilian
Beast had a screaming policeman in its
jaws a strange statue was standing on
top of a pile of bodies all with broken
necks and a horde of flesh-eating
zombies chased some terrified civilians
into broken storefronts in short all
hell is breaking loose and you're right
there in the middle of it as you try to
avoid the Legion of hungry Undead you
see a beautiful woman beckoning you into
an alley you run to her hoping that
you'll have found some way out but when
you're in there and alone with her
desperately clutching the one pocket
knife you manage to grasp in your
trembling hand before your house was
overrun by flesh-eating insects she
begins to laugh at you the woman starts
to change right before your eyes her
flowing red dress transforms into
impenetrable Sam MRI armor her features
become hard and severe and a deathly
sharp Katana begins to manifest in her
hand as the anomalous swordsman walks
towards you on this the most terrifying
day of your life you realize that you
probably won't live to see Sundown one
of the most terrifying scenarios
explored in The Archives of the SCP
Foundation is that of scp-5000 events
during which the foundation's primary
directive changes from the study and
containment of anomalies to the
extinction of all human life what would
you do in the shoes of a foundation
researcher during
scp-5000 what anomalies would you use to
kill people or stop certain groups of
interest from taking down the foundation
we posed this question to you the
viewers of SCP explained on our
community tab with one caveat you can't
use any nuclear weapons or any anomalies
that can totally destroy the world
quickly so without further Ado let's see
what kind of destruction you all rot Leo
World said as a researcher I would use
the radio to make people hear the words
of
scp-4511 the swine God to make them
sacrifice others to his burning insides
it's good to let a less popular SCP have
some Spotlight in this scenario perhaps
this idea could also be used for some
groups of Interest this response reminds
me of something my grandma used to say
if you have to wipe out the human race
in order to destroy a horrifying entity
lurking in the collective unconscious
you might as well get creative with it
oh she was a strange lady anyway all
hail the swine God made his eternal
flame cleanse the Earth but this
particular strategy would probably take
a while to have an effect on the
population at large but points for
originality you see bite said I think a
picture of scp-096 would make an
excellent weapon against groups of
Interest small lightweight discreet
guaranteed death of the Target now this
is a classic if it ain't broke don't fix
it if you've got a killing machine ready
to be deployed as soon as someone looks
at his face why not take advantage of
that the only potential hang up is the
problem of getting the picture to the
groups of Interest without looking at
them yourself once you've got a system
down then you can just spread 096's
picture around and watch the body count
rack up this strategy is a lot like
playing Call of Duty it also destroys
lives with a headshot Derek McDaniel
said
scp-2501 think about it a telekinetic
claw that can Crush potentially anything
while keeping a safe distance from any
threats it's a perfect weapon for
stealth hitting prior targets and more
no muss no fuss just a telekinetic claw
great thinking ghosts of the Cove said
okay this is gonna take a while number
one wake 239 up and tell her about the
chaos Insurgency show her videos of
their raids on Foundation sites
basically do everything to make them
look like the bad guys if all goes well
she'll wipe them out from existence like
she did with the d-class rinse and
repeat for any gois that come off as
hostile number two use scp-038 to clone
anomalies that can cause death for
example clone scp-4955 find field agents
who specialize in melee combat and send
them out into densely populated areas
number three blast recordings of scps
336 661 and 2284's voices on radio
stations all over the world have 336's
recordings be as long as possible get
661 to spread destructive thoughts over
and over on recording and make 2284
state that there's a safe Zone at
scp-2316 so that people head over and
recognize the Bodies In The Water number
four airdrop scp-469 into Delhi India
which is the world's noisiest City
according to google number five using a
front company distribute pamphlets full
of instructions on how to survive the
event on one of the pages of the
pamphlet print the descriptions of
several deadly info hazardous scps 1128
2316 Etc and finally number six
integrate
scp-3280 into the water cycle so this is
the way the world goes out not with a
bang not with a whimper but with a fleet
of gaslighting knives potentially deadly
radio broadcasts a city crushed by a
mass of wings and killer anomalies
disguised as life-saving resources and
then the global Water Supply being
slowly replaced by Sapient water that
hates humans is there a word for being
impressed and terrified at the same time
because if there is you'll find my
picture next to it in the dictionary
said to ensure all children disappear I
would stop answering scp-3034 the
counting station no matter how well
hidden or protected some kids will be
they should disappear eventually I'm
just also really curious what would
happen I find that SCP spooky and
fascinating well that's absolutely
terrifying I can only imagine the chaos
that would ensue once the adults noticed
that all the children in the world had
vanished you probably wouldn't even need
anomalous measures to take care of them
their paranoia and rage would do the
rest this isn't the most efficient
method but it is the one that feels most
like an unpublished Stephen King novel
so you've got that going for you cheat
code Masters said I always keep a half
inch model of the original generation
one Devastator from Transformers in my
pocket I could put scp-914 on the very
fine setting go into the input hold my
half-inch Devastator in the palm of my
hand and as the door closes shout
prepare to meet your doom nothing can
withstand the might of Devastator and
then I'll personally unleash my full
destructive potential as the 120 meter
tall combiner it's officially documented
in Transformers lore that though Mass
displacement technology combiners not
only become bigger than the sum of their
parts but Godzilla sized before we get
into the plan itself you always keep a
half inch model the original Generation
1 Devastator from Transformers in your
pocket just want to make sure I heard
that right no judgment clearly you have
a good reason and that reason is that
one day you'll be able to use the
Clockworks to transform yourself into a
120 meter tall Devastator and obliterate
all of humanity in the most ambitious
crossover event of all time legendary
hydrogen said I would use the nerfing
gun in order to use it on the groups of
interest to devolve them into cavemen
but also against the people we're trying
to kill as well then let them kill each
other in territorial struggles while
they also wouldn't be aware of attacks
by the other scps that have been
released making wiping out Humanity
faster and much more easier to get done
before scp-5000 could do their reset
button I had no idea we had so many
super villains in the scp-explained
audience using the nerfing gun to Nerf
all Humanity now that is truly on
another level release 682 Into The Fray
and things will get downright
prehistoric Nevermore ghouls said as a
researcher I suggest you unleashing a
cp053 the little girl into any large
survival bunkers or communities that
enemy organizations have created to save
Humanity easy to sneaker in and cause a
mass amount of death due to her
abilities as to how to get her
cooperation in killing all life promise
her more play time with scp-682 okay
seriously people these are getting
downright diabolical since the young
girl seems to be unaware of her effect
on people you probably wouldn't have to
promise her anything in fact maybe it's
best that she doesn't know she's being
used as a pawn in a plan to wipe out all
of humankind why pile on extra trauma
during the apocalypse right silver
chroma said while I have been a fan of
SCP for years now so here's what I would
do number one get a hold of scp-079 or
the self-learning computer number two
put it on a little cart that was used to
roll in a TV at school number three go
into 682's containment site number four
strike a deal with it since I know that
079 and 682 have a form of friendship
then it could work number five if the
deal fails then get scp-999 to hug him
until he becomes way less hostile and
agrees to help us the deal being that if
he does help then he will be allowed to
leave the facility to a more open area
in certain range and he will get a few
d-class personnel as play things number
six get the assistance of scp-343 to
help us get rid of the Menace and
rebuild the world a bit better number
seven get the Brilliance of the smartest
scps out there one of them being scp-049
since this could be the pestilence he
wanted to eradicate number eight let the
world know about the foundation and help
survivors and such like this was in
scp-001 when Daybreak scenario number
nine neutralize or terminate as cp5000
and number 10. rebuild the world a
bright spot of optimism in the darkness
not quite what the prompt was going for
but it is admirable you try to save
Humanity somehow and instead of just
burning it all down you might as well
give it a shot but be careful if you're
trying to save the world the SCP
Foundation itself is going to be gunning
for you and you'll be operating without
the organization's resources behind you
good luck xcm said here's an interesting
one 3008 the infinite Ikea makes signs
pointing to it that make it look like a
shelter and disguise it as one people
run in and they're trapped forever or at
least until they die due to the
employees so rather than destroying
Humanity directly you can just confine
them to an endless Purgatory of Swedish
meatballs and affordably priced
Furniture great way to get the job done
while keeping your hands technically
clean vlast gaming said I'd use scp-2000
with a modification that would inject
all the Clones with scp-008 to create an
endless never-ending horde of zombies to
release into the world if the site is
never retaken and allowed to continue
this process I could in theory have a
legit endless supply of
scp-008-1s to swarm the world with ah
The Walking Dead approach you gotta give
it up for the classics a good old zombie
apocalypse with an SCP Foundation twist
always ra said I suspect humanitarian
Aid packages will be deployed by
do-gooders at some point if so slip in a
set of scp-178 into one of the larger
refugee camps since third parties caught
up in a 178 incident are also vulnerable
to attack job done and since any
sufficiently large group of people will
have at least one goofball among them
this could help wreck major trade routes
during the earlier days or weeks I
always had a feeling that the decline of
the human race would start with a pair
of 3D glasses everyone told me I was out
of my mind and that I'd have to leave my
showing of Avatar the way of water
without a refund but look at me now I
was right all along
Kirby Kona said as a researcher in this
scenario I'd find scp-743 the deadly
infinite chocolate fountain and place it
into scp-914 the Clockworks on either
fine or very fine if on very fine it's
still able to be moved and carried I'd
take it to a refugee camp and wait wait
until the now improved creatures tear
those who are resisting the foundation
to shreds ooh death by chocolate well
death by swarms of anomalous anthropods
emerging from a chocolate fountain but
that just doesn't sound as good either
way that is a sweet victory genre 18
said so if the goal is as I understand
it to wipe out the entire human race
without using reality warping scps of
any kind there are a number of options
to choose from first I'd start with
scp-2419 and let lose the thousands of
unliving d-class who have had every
trace of humanity wiped from their souls
they should be more than eager to rack
up as high a body count as possible then
I'd use scps capable of Target specific
areas or population centers like scp-923
a satellite whose Rays drive people into
a murderous Rage or
scp-2617 a Russian radio tower that can
summon an army of ice soldiers to
exterminate anything within a
pre-programmed set of coordinates also
while there is no shortage of
bloodthirsty scps out there including
scp-082 AKA Ferdinand the cannibal or
scp-953 the polymorphic humanoid I'd
start with a bigger gun
scp-353 AKA Vector is a 26 year old girl
with the ability to absorb contain
manipulate and release viruses as she
pleases she also happens to Delight in
killing as many people as she can so I
have a feeling she'd be more than happy
to help even against other agencies out
to combat the foundation I may have been
thinking about this for a while you
don't say thank you genre for one of the
most in-depth and terrifying responses
to our prompt and on behalf of humanity
thank you for channeling this energy
into s CP related Pursuits instead of
bringing about the actual apocalypse
between the Laughing men the Rogue
satellite the Russian radio tower and
Vector humanity and the Dark Passenger
that dwells deep within every human
psyche doesn't stand a chance now go
check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
how scp-682 tried to stop scp-5000 for
more